[Music]
there are a lot of factors that make
Florida weird it is not like any other
state that I know of in the sense that
there is no Florida that mean there is
Miami where I live which is Latin
America there mean it is I mean you
spend any time you know AME you will
discover that not only is it Latin
America but it's more and more Latin
America every day if you go south into
the keys it's the 60s if you go west to
Naples it's Ohio if you go north to Boca
it's Long Island if you go to to Orlando
it's like a you know Russian limousine
drivers driving you know tourists from
everywhere in the world all you know
around and if you go much north than
that it becomes Georgia and Alabama so
it is really not one state has no
coherence at all and and I think less so
as the time goes by it's a vacation spot
so you have people coming down there
just you know to have fun a few people
who are not feeling in it necessarily in
a serious mood yeah it's a very
transient state so you have a lot of
people again who don't don't feel rooted
there but are just there because it's
you know convenient or the weather's
nice or whatever and it it's it's not
it's a pretty corrupt state I mean our
governments we've had a lot of
corruption in Florida and and it's
convenient to you know all kinds of
borders so it's I mean it's very easy to
get there from the Caribbean from Latin
America whatever so if you wanted a
smuggle something Florida's a great
place to start so the result of this is
it's just kind of this very loose very
non structured very non traditional
state where anything feels like it could
happen it's kinda like if you made Las
Vegas much bigger and with less controls
you know not that the efficiency of the
casinos in the Las Vegas police
department just as kind of a big area
where people feel they can do things and
so people come from everywhere to party
to do whatever to do commit to commit
criminal acts and it's the weather's
warm so you can always be outside and
you know there's always a party going on
somewhere
it's just conducive to weird things
happening my argument has been for a
long time that we are not it's not so
much Floridians who are weird and I
consider myself when I've been there 30
years it's it's people come to Florida
we are like the Ellis Island for weird
stupid people they come to come to
Florida to commit stupid acts if if when
one example I like to use you know they
got an international publicity a woman
was arrested driving south on the
Overseas Highway from Miami Tiki to Key
West B she had an accident because she
was shaving her bikini region while
while driving well she actually had
outsourced the steering to her her
passenger she was in a hurry to see her
boyfriend in Key West this is all
according to the police report so she
decided rather than pull over the side
of the road to shave her bikini region
she'd keep going and outsource the
steering to her passenger who was as it
happened in this way it's a Florida
story her ex-husband so there they're
driving south 40 miles an hour she's
shaving but not looking at the road just
operating you accelerate your steering
you know what could possibly go wrong
anyway the car in front of them slows
down they slam into it there's an
accident international news they don't
you know as all Florida stories are you
know oh can you believe it this woman
she's shaving her bikini area while
driving - you know the woman was from
Indiana that's the key she was shaving
her Hoosier so which is I think with
that term butwe Florida gets the blame
for that but it's actually you know it's
it's somebody who came to Florida and
that's so often the case if somebody
decides he wants to pleasure himself
into a stuffed animal in Walmart that
person's gonna wherever he is he's gonna
go to Florida to commit that act and you
know this is why we have so many people
doing just so many weird things naked
with reptiles we have a lot of reptiles
also
you